[Music]
there are very few films and filmmakers
today that
tell a beautiful meaningful story
that also has grit and a soul
you know what's really interesting about
this story is it's it's three
themes that are very common in film that
converge
so you have a survival story uh hide
under that don't make a sound
no matter what you see you have a
coming-of-age story
are you someone i can trust and you have
a redemption story all woven into one
i was a coward
as much as i can ever make the world
feel a character i want to do that
the one thing you can count on with him
is it's going to be real
i try to do everything i can practically
and when they ask me how am i going to
recreate the fire i said well i'm going
to go out in the desert and i'm going to
build a 300 acre forest and i'm going to
set it on fire
this is a story about overcoming and
getting past and it's wrapped in this
amazing world of fire and madness
give them something else to worry about
it's
quite rare in film to get that kind of
pure thriller aspect with these
wonderful survivalist
characters it is about being up against
the people who are pursuing you but also
the elements which prove to be
more powerful than any of the people
this film is going to be absolutely
amazing it's like roller coaster of
action
right now taylor sheridan is a great
american storyteller
he understands the west he understands
the wilderness he understands what it
means to survive and to live off the
land
he just has an understanding of the
characters and what the truth is of what
they'd be doing
and of the landscapes and the
environments and he manages to ground in
a very real way
think about essence and talent and depth
of character and the physical ability
and someone i would believe in that role
angie certainly fits all of those bills
and uh
i don't know that i would have done it
if angie if angie hadn't agreed
i'm so happy to be pushed by somebody to
just toughen up and
get dirty and sweaty and do things i've
never done
you missed a boy the film is
a pursuit thriller in the american west
he tells this story about this little
boy and this woman and these men coming
after him
this is a bigger movie than movies he's
made in the past got blood in your shirt
there's more action it drives me what
are you waiting for it's very much about
one thing kind of leading into another
but taylor will always root it in
authenticity and it will always be
grounded in reality
somebody's gonna see a story that i tell
i want them to be riveted from the
minute they sit down
this film is a great thriller great
adventure
cross and unusual terrain inside a great
fire
[Music]
[Music]
you